bonjour et bienvenue pour ce septième
cour de paléo mammalogie consacrée
aujourd'hui à l'amérique du sud
alors pourquoi vouloir pourquoi vouloir
parler de l'amérique du sud
spécifiquement m'a déjà parce que
l'amérique du sud a connu une histoire
d'isolement très semblable à celle de
l'afrique durant tout le sénat zoé qui
en fait elle est même plus extrême que
l'afrique puisque comme l'afrique
l'isolément commence au crétacé avec
justement la rupture de l'isthme de
panama mais c'est isme de panama en fait
ne se reformera qu'il y à deux millions
d'années donc donc en fait l'amérique du
sud va être complètement isolé les âmes
les mammifères d'amérique du sud vont
être vont ils vont évoluer en total
isolement du reste des autres mammifères
pendant quasiment tout le cénozoïque et
est en fait ne parler que des dizaines
d'arbres moderne ça ne rend pas du tout
justice à cette diversité
donc voilà c'est l'histoire de
l'amérique du sud c'est l'histoire en
fait d'une expérience évolutif qui a
duré pendant tout le cénozoïque et qui a
démarré dès le crétacé donc dès
l'apparition des des mamies des groupes
de manifeste place un terme moderne et
donc on va voir aujourd'hui quelles sont
ces groupes de mammifères donc donc au
même titre en fait que l'australie
l'australie est aussi un très bon
exemple de comment les mammifères ont
évolué en total isolement du reste du
monde donc vous avez les marsupiaux et
les mots notres m qui sont ces
l'australie est le seul endroit où on
trouve les marsupiaux et les mots notres
m et comme on l'a souligné dans le tout
premier cours eh bien ils ont ils ont en
fait évoluer de façon convergente des
caractéristiques qu'on retrouve chez les
placentaire et donc on va voir comment
l'évolution a eu lieu en amérique du sud
donc déjà c'était cet isolement il
commence au crétacé et déjà des le
crétacé on peut constater les effets de
cet isolement sur la faune sud
américaines et notamment des l'existence
d'espèces qui ont la particularité
d'être absolument gigantesque donc
l'argentinosaurus le gigantisme
les lots gigantosaurus voilà c'est pas
un hasard en fait si on retrouve ces
deux ces deux grands dinosaures ces deux
dinosaures géants en amérique du sud
donc respectivement l'un des plus grand
sauropode est l'un des plus grands
théropodes probablement d'ailleurs plus
grand que le t-rex c'est pas pour rien
qu'on si on les retrouve en amérique du
sud c'est parce que c'est parce que le
continent déjà commencé à être isolé et
commencer à voir se développer une faune
relativement endémique donc
l'argentinosaurus et un titanosaures
idée donc c'est un groupe de dinosaures
qu'on retrouve principalement dans
l'ancien gondwana donc c'est pas encore
une faune hyper isolé non plus et puis
là le gigantosaurus à quelques affinités
avec les aloses au rider donc mais bon
voilà le déjà là on commence à avoir
déjà des le crétacé l'amérique du sud
commence à avoir une faune atypique et
c'est donc à cette époque là que les
premiers mammifères donc les groupes de
mammifères modernes je veux dire vont
commencer aussi a évolué et donc vont
vont être aussi victime de cet isolement
alors une chose qu'il faut noter c'est
que malgré l' isolement et bien le
l'effet delà de la chute de l'astéroïde
à lille i à 66 millions d'années va être
le même
en amérique du sud qu'ailleurs dans le
monde à savoir disparition des
dinosaures mais pas des mammifères et ça
ça c'est un des arguments forts en
faveur d'un événement cosmique en fait
puisque un événement localiser
finalement n'aurait pas tellement eu les
mêmes effets partout dans le monde et là
curieusement même si l'amérique du sud
est isolé même si l'australie est isolé
et bien ces deux continents vont avoir
une histoire très similaires les grands
dinosaures non aviens vont disparaître
alors que des mammifères vont résister
alors commençons déjà par par
caractérisé cette faune mammalienne
sud-américaine et premièrement et bien
intéressons nous aux carnivores
alors les cas justement point n'est de
karni vohra en afrique en amérique du
sud l'amérique du sud en amérique du sud
les carnivores dominant ce ne sont pas
particulièrement des mammifères en tout
cas ce ne sont pas que les mammifères
ce sont surtout les faux russe racid et
donc tels que for us racault ce qu'on
appelle aussi les oiseaux de terreur
donc vous voyez ici frustré à cause qui
datent du pliocène et donc s'efforcera
cidc oiseaux terreur en fait ils
apparaissent dès le paléo scène et ils
ne disparaissent qu au pléistocène ils
vont même survivre après que le détroit
de paname que le l'isthme de panama ne
se reforme
vous pouvez voir donc les frustre acide
et qui sont caractérisés par un bec avec
un crochet les faux rustre acide est on
avec aussi qui est très étroit c'est une
tronçonneuse un évidemment le leur bec
donc très puissant de désinsertion
musculaire très importante à l'arrière
du crâne d une vision binoculaire aussi
est évidemment réduction des bras donc
ce sont des coureurs et minal ce sont
des oiseaux coureurs pas des oiseaux
volants et ils ont des griffes
absolument gigantesque et pointue à
céret donc dessert extrêmement à céret
donc vous pouvez voir une reconstitution
ici dans nos attin en train de
pourchasser
de pourchasser c'est une bonne question
ça m'a l'air d'être un capybara enfin
rongeurs de type capybara est ici à nos
attin alors il ya une chose qu'il faut
savoir à propos des oiseaux terreur
c'est qu'il faut surtout pas les
confondre avec les gars storni ty et
donc les gars store ni d'idées ce sont
les oiseaux qu'on avait les grands
oiseaux coureurs qu'on avait à l'eocène
en europe et alors ils se ressemblent
beaucoup un superficiellement et la
plupart du temps quand vous cherchez des
informations sur les gars storni ty et
vous tombez en réalité sur des faux
rustre acide et ils sont complètement
différent les castors nitti des défauts
sur rue sera side est donc déjà le bec
crochu chez les foreurs incident est
alors qu'il est plat chez les gars
storni télé et ça c'est parce que les
gars ce turn it idées sont en fait
herbivore ils ne sont pas carnivores
comme le sont les faux russe racid et ça
nous est montrée par l'anatomie du bec
donc mais ça nous et surtout montrer par
là les analyses géochimiques qui ont été
faits sur les autres gars star nette
idée et qui montre que la chimie osseuse
est plus compatible avec un régime
herbivore qu'un régime carnivore et est
donc ça veut dire que gastaud rnis se
nourrissait de graines de fruits de
feuilles
bref que c'était que c'était un
herbivore et l'herbe ivory se voit aussi
donc sur ces sur ses jambes
les laits métatarse sont relativement
courts ça lorsqu'on appelle le tarse au
métatarse chez les oiseaux parce que
tout est fusionnée donc le tarse au
métatarse et très est très court chez
les gars ce turn it idée alors qu'il est
très allongée chez les fauries strass
idée ce sont des oiseaux coureurs
d'ailleurs leurs plus proches parents
vous voyez c'est le sait le seriez m'a
donc il ya encore des des proches
parents modernes défaut rue sera si dès
qu'on appelle les séries emma est donc
ce sont des vous pouvez voir les
métatarse qui sont extrêmement allongé
chez les séries emma et aujourd'hui ce
sont toujours des carnivores d'ailleurs
ils se nourrissent de petits vertébrés
tels des serpents par exemple d'aider
les arts etc
les castors need idée aussi alors on a
trouvé des empreintes de pas de gaston
need idées et ils ont en fait des il
avait en fait des sabots sur leurs
griffes y avait sur leur sert il n'avait
pas de griffes
contrairement aux fonds russe racid est
donc globalement et ans et en plus la
distribution des castors nette idée est
strictement hémisphère nord donc
amérique du nord et europe
on n'a jamais trouvé de gaston et idées
en amérique du sud
donc en plus ça n'a rien à voir avec ça
n'a rien à voir niveau distribution
géographique et enfin les plus proches
parents des gars stansted et ce ne sont
pas les séries
à ce sont les canards et autres soient
modernes
voilà en tout cas d'après ce qu'on peut
en dire par là par la morphologie et
vous pouvez voir aussi d'ailleurs
gastaud rnis le muscle temporal est
complètement différent là la morphologie
temporal est complètement différente de
celle de défauts rustre acide et donc
voilà ne confondez plus gaston nitti des
efforts us tracy des sas et les oiseaux
terreur et ça c'est gastaud ça ce sont
les gars storni ty et donc gastaud rnis
on appelle aussi dit atream a donc c'est
pareil dia trima c'est un gars storni
tdc vous voir même sega stores nice
d'ailleurs il ya certaines personnes qui
disent qu diatribes à egat storni ce
sont en fait le même genre
donc voilà on ne confond plus gaston
need idées et for us rassis délégua
storni des dons jamais mis les pieds en
amérique du sud
évidemment au niveau des carnivores je
rappelle l'existence des bords yens
idées ou des spas ratio dotted et si
vous préférez vous pouvez dire ce par
aso séparation dont tu as et le groupe
le plus grand borias ni décès la famille
donc c'est l'ordre et la famille
respectivement et donc ce sont les
fameux marsupiaux à dents de sabre dont
vous pouvez voir ici les dents de sabre
qui se prolonge je le rappelle très
fortement à l'intérieur du crâne
contrairement à celle de smilodon le
cerveau qui est très petit la suture
entre le jus galles et le square aux
halles qui est qu' à cette langue qui se
prolonge vers l'arrière jusqu'à
l'articulation de la mâchoire
donc ça c'est aussi un très fortement
marsupial il y à une bagarre post
orbitaire qu'il n'y a pas chez smilodon
et vous avez un deux trois quatre
molaires comme chez les marsupiaux donc
voilà c'est juste une main petit rappel
qu'il y avait aussi les par aso dont
idées qui étaient des carnivores qui
partageait le terrain avec les faux
rustre acide et alors les insectivores
maintenant alors bon les insectivores on
va pas s'y attarder trop longtemps mais
il ya quand même un groupe auquel
dont j'aimerais vous parler et ce groupe
en fait c'est une sorte de taupes qui
s'appelle nécro l'espèce alors vous
pouvez voir au niveau de sa morphologie
si vous vous rappelez la tronche qui ont
les tops doré et les taupes européenne
vous pouvez voir que ça c'est dur c'est
de la taupe
on ne peut plus tôt pas je veux dire
donc les gros doigts le crâne qui est
très large à l'arrière et qui est très
fin à lavant les dents qui sont
fortement triangulaire mais en fait les
driollet cette idée donc la famille à
laquelle ni nécro l'espèce appartient ne
sont même pas des mammifères
placentaires ni même des mammifères
marsupiaux
ce sont ce ne sont même pas des
mammifères terriens ce ne sont même pas
des terriens se sont même pas des méta
terriens ou dut rien voilà c'est là où
je veux en venir
ce son valet voyez là c'est le groupe
des teria ici et là en fait vous avez un
autre groupe celui des driollet cette
idée dans lequel vous trouverez et bien
nécro l'espèce et nécro l'espèce en fait
c'est un survivant qui a vécu survécu
jusqu'au mis en scène en fait d'un
groupe qui a autrefois était très
abondants au crétacé mais qui s'est
quasiment complètement éteint à la fin
du cénozoïque quasiment parce que
justement nécro l'espèce a survécu alors
qu'est ce qui montre que nécro l'estey
ce n'est pas un mammifère teria va
regarder la cochlée n'est pas aussi
enroulée que chez les mammifères
terriens et la morphologie dentaire
n'est même pas n'est même pas tribos
phoenix voyez cette molaires alabau être
triangulaire donc elle a beau imiter la
lampe todo ci ou là zalando d'aussi des
mammifères
insectivores elle n'est pas du tout
tribos phoenix vous voyez que c'est on
n'a pas du tout un protocole parra codm
et akon là on a juste 3 3 3 sortes de
caunes dans chaque angle mais c'est tout
quoi c'est une morphologie dentaire qui
est extrêmement simple qui n'a rien à
voir avec la dent tribos phoenix donc
voila c est ce donc que cette cette
survivance d'un groupe sud-américain
directement issu du crétacé n'a été
permise justement que par l' isolement
de l'amérique du sud
donc c'est assez tard d'aidé c'est une
des espèces en fait les plus
remarquables de d'amérique du sud les
driot le driollet cette idée née crawl
est est-ce parce que justement c'était
un c'était un fossile vivant
non je déconne voyez que ses ancêtres
n'étaient pas des taux pas vous voyez le
crâne de chronos piot c'est un petit
crâne d'un secteur mais pas de taupins
donc évidemment nécro l'espèce a évolué
en fait c'est cette ce mode de vie
fouisseurs a certainement été un refuge
pour les derniers driollet cette idée
qui se sont adaptés à ce mode de vie
très très très dérivés on va dire ce qui
leur a permis finalement de d'échapper à
la concurrence des autres mammifères et
notamment d'autres petits mammifères
comme les rongeurs ou les primates par
exemple qui sont arrivés au courant de
l'éocène et de l'oligocène et maintenant
donc qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau
des herbivores et bien au niveau des
herbivores on va aussi avoir une faune
qui sera totalement différente de ce
qu'on rencontre dans le reste du monde
donc y aura pas de paix risso d'actes il
n'y aura pas de paix non gül et il y
aura pas darciaux dactyle et s'il n'ya
pas darciaux dactyle j'aimerais attirer
votre attention sur le fait qu'il n'y
aura pas de l'ama et oui vous avez bien
entendu l'amérique du sud sans lama ça a
l'air d'être un peu bizarre dit comme ça
mais c'est vrai alors qu'est-ce qu'on a
si on n'a pas de tout ce qu'on appelle
communément les ongulés eh bien on va
avoir d'autres types de mammifères qui
vont prendre la place des ongulés et
notamment on va avoir les rongeurs donc
les rongeurs qui vont arriver il ya qui
arrive en amérique du sud à travers
l'atlantique il ya 40 millions d'années
rappelez-vous du cours sur les
micromammifères
vont faire partie de la faune des
herbivores qui des méga herbivores
notamment joseph aux artigues asia un
proche cousin donc du capi barras mais
qui va pousser la grande taille beaucoup
plus loin donc les capybaras et
aujourd'hui encore le plus grand rongeur
qui existent donc de la taille d'un
petit cochon mais le jeu est faux artiga
dia vous voyez on est plutôt du côté du
rhinocéros de sumatra au niveau de la
taille
et vous voyez cette reconstitution assez
effrayante de joseph aux artigues asia
il ya aussi évidemment les primates qui
sont des herbivores et qui vont être les
herbivores arboricole donc pareil il
arriva il ya 40 millions d'années et ils
vont à coup ils vont avoir le rôle de
des herbivores de la canopée
mais surtout on va avoir des équivalent
sud-américain des ongulés alors qu'on
appelle qu on regroupe sous le terme
générique de mairie dit augure meridian
gül et méridionaux du latin mais c'est
un terme qui est extrêmement trompeurs
parce qu'il sous-entend que tous et tout
ce petit monde formé un groupe monofil
éthique alors que non enfin non jusqu'à
preuve du contraire non
il est très probable que les méridiens
ont bu la tasse n'était pas n'était pas
monofil éthiques
donc qu'est ce qu'on entend par méridien
gül à tabac à l'intérieur des méridiens
du latin on a par contre des groupes
monofil éthique des groupes monofil
éthique que sont les noms tant gül et
donc qui apparaissent dès le paléo scène
et qui vont persister jusqu'au
pléistocène
on va avoir l'hélicoptère qui
apparaissent au paléo scène et qui
persiste jusqu'aux pléistocène désastre
à pau terre que vous pouvez donc vous
pouvez voir la convergence évolutive
magnifique avec les éléphants qui
apparaissent au paléo saine et constitue
jusqu au pléistocène et les pires aux
terres convergence évolutive avec les
tapirs slash hippopotames slash
éléphants ils font un peu de tout les
pires aux terres
c'est alors les pires aux terres c'est
peut-être un peu le seul groupe qui est
problématique parce que dernièrement en
fait il ya eu des files aux génies qui
ont placé les pires aux terres à
l'intérieur des notes ont bull et donc
peut-être que les pires aux terres ne
sont qu un sous groupe dénonçant gueulé
ce qui ne ferait qu'augmenter
l'extraordinaire diversité des noms
tombe gul et parce que chez les notes
angulaire on a de tout depuis des petits
animaux qui ressemblaient à des lapins
jusqu'à des animaux gigantesques qui
ressemblaient à des rhinocéros donc donc
ça ne ferait en gros qu'augmenter la la
la formidable diversité des noctambules
et alors au niveau morphologiques
comment on va reconnaître tous ces
animaux alors on va commencer par les
pires aux terres et par les astres à pau
terre parce que ce sont deux groupes qui
se ressemble beaucoup au final les pires
aux terres comme astra potter vont avoir
des des défenses de grosses défenses à
l'avant sauf que chez les pires aux
terres ce sont les incisives qui vont
former les défenses donc elles sont
implantées dans le pré maxillaire 1
alors que chez les astres à pau terre ce
sont les canines qui vont former les
défenses et vous pouvez le voir il ya la
suture entre le prix max hilaire et le
maxillaire et donc les canines sont
implantés dans le maxillaire
donc même si on a des grosses défenses
chez les deux et qu'on a aussi
d'ailleurs une rétraction du museau ce
qui fait qu'il ya une rétraction des
narines ce qui fait qu'ils sont
reconstruits avec des trompe
eh bien eh bien ils sont différenciables
par la nature en fête de leur défense
leur défense donc qui sont d'une d'un
côté des incisif chez les pires aux
terres et de l'autre des canines la
morphologie des molaires c'est pareil
vous les différences entre pas avec la
morphologie des molaires parce qu'ils
sont tous les deux lots faut donc
donc on a une très très forte
convergence avec les pennons gueulé et
avec les tapirs aussi d'ailleurs il
avait aussi un peu l'air de tapir
d'abord des tapirs avec des grosses
défenses c'est des éléphants voilà donc
donc belle qu'on va bel exemple encore
une fois de convergence évolutive che
désastre à pau terre et les pires aux
terres mais les deux groupes qui sont
vraiment les groupes dominants en
amérique du sud ce sont les notes
ongulés l'hélicoptère donc d'abord on va
voir les notes ont gueulé donc une diapo
entière rien que pour les noctambules
et chez nous engueuler comme je vous
disais on a de tout de petits animaux
qui avaient l'air de lapin donc on a des
animaux de petite taille avec un crâne
avec un crâne qui est définitivement le
même que celui des autres nous engueuler
mais qui ont de grosses bulles
tympanique qui indique donc qu'ils
avaient de grandes oreilles et des
attaches pour les oreilles aussi qu'ils
sont assez grandes donc vraiment des
petits animaux avec des grandes oreilles
et des membres sauteur aussi donc très
forte convergence avec les lapins ça
s'appelle pro typo terium et donc les
pros type autorités ont vécu de
l'oligocène au pliocène principaux
terium lui-même je crois et du miocène
donc voilà ça vivait dans la pampa et ça
a sauté jetons restants ils ont dit oui
c'était très ça devait être très drôle à
voir et l'un des noctambules et les plus
connus c'est toxo dont toxo donkey et
qui est le nôtre gül et je pense le plus
emblématique
vous voyez ici l'animal en question
alors cherchez pas assaini impéritie au
tactile ni un arsenal qu'il vous pouvez
voir là il ya trois gros doigts qui ont
tous la même taille notamment
donc c'est ceni de l'arceau d'actine ni
dupes et risso dactyle c'est vraiment un
groupe dont bull et qui est complètement
à part en fait totalement totalement à
part il ya certaines ya certaines
personnes qui ont proposé que
possiblement il était apparenté au
paiement gueulé mais c'est une hypothèse
qui a pas qui est pas retenu plus que ça
dans la littérature quoi c'est vraiment
et ils ont une morphologie dentaire qui
est complètement différente de tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer
ils ont
ils ont aucun diastème aucun dit à ce
thème dans la mâchoire
ils n'ont pas de barbe post orbitaire ce
qui est très rare chez les ongulés par
contre ils ont des sabots ils sont dix
jti grade
enfin ils sont en buli grade par dont
vous pouvez voir
et alors ce qui va caractériser
réellement les notes ont gueulé autre
autre que les caractères convergent avec
d'autres espèces de placentaire et bien
ça va être la bulletin panique
les noctambules et ont une bulletin
panique avec ce qu'on appelle un sinus
et pittin panique donc
ici c'est la bulle tympanique en coupe
donc là vous avez l'endroit où se trouve
leur est interne c'est-à-dire le pétrin
au milieu donc avec ici le nerf qui est
connecté à l'oreille interne ici en
dessous donc vous avez là bulletin
panique en coupe donc la caisse de
résonance de l'oreille et au dessus vous
avez le sinus et pittin panique qui donc
est un comme un sinus nasale quoi une
poche d'air dans l'os c'est une poche
d'air à l'intérieur de l'os mais qui est
attachée à l'oreille en fait et qui est
attachée à la bulletin panique donc
est-ce que ça augmentait la caisse de
réseaux de résonance je ne sais pas on
ne connaît pas la fonction biologique de
ce sinistre panique mais en tout cas
c'est vraiment une signature un
caractère signature des notes ongulés
qu'ils soient de la taille d'un
rhinocéros ou de la taille d'un lapin
vous retrouverez systématiquement ce
sinus et pittin panique
voilà donc sinus et pittin panique comme
c'est écrit ici et de l'autre côté
l'autre groupe de demain dont bull est
dominant
en amérique du sud ce sont les lits
taupe terne donc l'élite hop terne qui
qui donc sont ces étranges mammifères ah
j'ai oublié de préciser donc on sait que
c'est des placentaires l'hélicoptère
n'est notons gül et les pires aux terres
et c'est donc tous ces mammifères en gül
et je reviens quelques diapos en arrière
on sait que ce sont des placentaires
tout simplement parce qu'on voit leurs
formules dentaire parce que c'est vrai
que je grille un peu les étapes je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il y avait des
marsupiaux qui était carnivore alors
pourquoi il y aurait pas des marsupiaux
herbivores bon bah pourquoi je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que vous avez une deux trois mots
l'air et une quatrième prime une
quatrième prémolaires qui est mollahs
reform
donc voilà on est sur du placentaire
donc on se calme on boit frais on voit
la cdu placentaire n'y a pas de doute
là-dessus par contre
d'où ça sort quels sont les plus proches
parents de ces animaux on a une petite
idée je vous y amènerait je vous dis
amènerait dans le courant de ce diable
mais voilà c'est des groupes que dont on
dont on ne sait que très peu de chose en
réalité un notamment d'où ils sortent
quelles sont leurs ancêtres c'est voilà
donc l'hélicoptère n'est bien c'est un
groupe qui est que dont vous connaissez
peut-être au moins un représentant qui
est macro kenya puisqu'il a été propre
et popularisée par la bbc et qui est
reconnaissable à cette trompe
alors on dit que macro kenya une trompe
pas ce que vous pouvez voir que ses
narines ne sont pas terminal elles sont
situées sur le sommet de son crâne
alors certes oui chez les tapirs chez
les pires aux terres on aime bien dire
qu'il ya une trompe parce que les
narines sont rétractés mais chez ces
animaux ça s'accompagne de deux points
d'insertion de fos pour l'insertion de
muscles qui devait former une trompe
chez makro kenya on voit pas de fausses
ça veut pas dire qu'il en avait pas un
neutron pas mais par contre on voit pas
les fausses et ça ça pose problème ça ça
pose problème là vous voyez là le côté
là où on devrait avoir l'insertion des
muscles de la lèvre et le dessus aussi
là où on devrait aussi avoir insertion
des muscles des lèvres et ben y'a rien
donc macro kenya il y avait peut-être
une trompe peut-être qu'il y avait un
évent à la place parce que
et pourquoi et à quoi ça devait servir
alors là et à quoi ça pouvait ressembler
avec avec la viande par dessus une fois
reconstitué ben là franchement c'est ses
mystères et boules de gomme pour
employer une expression des années 90 et
alors ce qui est intéressant chez les
lip taupe terne par contre c'est la
convergence avec les persos d'actes il
est en fait j'ai même envie de dire la
convergence inverse avec les périodes
active c'est à dire que l'hélicoptère
non effectivement effectivement un doigt
du milieu qui est porteur de charge mais
par contre ce qu'on voit c'est que les
espèces les plus anciennes de
l'oligocène elle n'avait qu'un doigt et
qu'ensuite au cours du miocène puis du
pliocène et bien les doigts latéraux
vont se développer et on va avoir des
des macros des macros canidés donc comme
macro kenya qui ont en fait trois doigts
bon c'est une histoire ultra simplifié
en réalité il y à un pool d'espèces qui
s est maintenue de l'oligocène jusqu au
pliocène qui avait trois doigts et qui
en fait va donner plusieurs fois des
espèces que où les doigts latéraux vont
se réduire et donc ça donne cette
impression finalement que les cons a
évolué depuis un doigt jusqu'à 1 doit
plus de douala terreau plus puis trois
doigts bien développé non en réalité
c'est que tout le long en fait il ya des
espèces avec trois doigts à développer
qui ont existé et qui ont et dont
certaines se sont adaptés à un mode de
vie en milieu ouvert donc en milieu de
savane à partir de l'oligocène et au
milieu scène et qui donc vont voir les
doigts latéraux serait dur mais c'est
quand même marrant de mettre cette image
en personne enfin de mettre cette image
là comme ça parce que du coup ça fait
presque la tendance inverse en fait on a
envie de la lire dans l'autre sens
tellement on est habitué à voir les
l'évolution des des chevaux on a envie
de la lire dans ce sens là mais non en
réalité celui là est plus ancien que
celui de gauche est plus ancien que
celui droite c'est juste qu'en fait à
chaque fois il ya un ancêtre en commun à
trois doigts quoi c'est tout et
et alors et l'hélicoptère ni sont aussi
caractérisée du coup par leur allant de
une certaine allende d'oddo cie donc
vous pouvez voir notamment lektroluv qui
est le mur extérieur des dents qui est
complètement complètement en forme de w
vous avez les dents jusqu'aux assises
yves qui sont très massives presque mot
la risée vous voyez que là vous avez les
prémolaires mais après arriver à la
canine la canine et pas pointu et elle a
même vous voyez un petit un petit repli
1 5 go home et les incisives aussi ont
des petits replis et des 5000 hommes qui
augmente encore la surface de
mastication donc et encore une fois
aucun diastème donc des animaux vraiment
très très très spéciaux l'hélicoptère
est alors l'hélicoptère ne sait à peu
près les seuls animaux dont on a une
vague idée de où ils sortent quand on
regarde les fossiles donc l'hélicoptère
ne les voit là dans cet arbre
phylogénétique qui sont tout en haut et
en fait il se branche au sein d'un
groupe de condy la retraite ont encore
eu un encore ce fameux groupe des condi
la retarder un groupe de condy l'art
trop nos radios nord américain qui
s'appelle lady de l'odon idée donc du
nom de didot l'onu ce qui est un conte
dit l'art du paléocène d'amérique du
nord
donc voilà l'élite hop terne c'est à peu
près les seuls chez qui on retrouve
justement d un possible ancêtre en
amérique du nord et donc une possible
voix de dispersion avant que dès qu'il
se retrouve isolé en amérique du sud est
et je crois qu'ils partagent avec eux la
morphologie danse et de la morphologie
dentaire encore une fois c'est pas il
n'y a pas de mystère là dedans et un peu
de la morphologie de l'astragale aussi
donc il ya certains caractères de
l'astragale et de la morphologie
dentaire qui sont partagées avec les
didot l'odon idées qui sont un peu trop
spécialisées pour pour que je voulais
détails maintenant
alors ça c'est quand on regarde la
morphologie mais maintenant il se trouve
qu'en fait il ya certains hits octurn
donc comme macro kenya est certes un
autogoal et comme tôt que son nom qui
ont survécu jusqu'au pliocène donc macro
kenya et oxo dont ils ont survécu très
très tard et on retrouve leur reste
suffisamment bien préservés dans des
grottes pour qu'on ait vu en extraire
finalement
collagène est ce que la gêne on a pu en
du coup l'analyse et les séquences
d'acides aminés du collagène est en fait
les résultats ont montré que le toque ce
don et macro kenya forme d'un clad et
oui donc l'absence de diastème si ça se
trouve c'est peut-être un caractère de
ce groupe là mais vous voyez ça forme un
clad donc non seulement sa forme à clad
mais en plus sa forme cloud groupe frère
des périseaux dactyle donc un groupe
d'ailleurs aux racines fortement
implanté en amérique du nord et en asie
en moins en amérique du nord pour les
chevaux et en asie pour pour les tapirs
et les rhinocéros
donc on est on est sur un groupe dont on
aurait possiblement un ancêtre commun en
amérique du nord
voilà donc avec une branche qui se
seraient dispersés en amérique du sud
est une branche qui se seraient
dispersés en amérique du nord et en asie
ce qui serait d'ailleurs ce qui serait
d'ailleurs une
quelque chose d'assez particulier pour
alors asia terre l'est l'eurasie à terre
rappelez vous ils ont plutôt une origine
asiatique que américaine mais bref ce
serait pas complètement je veux dire les
lots razia terre c'est bien parce que
c'est bien parce qu'on les retrouve en
amérique et en asie qu'on les appelle
les lots razia terre et pas seulement
les eurasia terre voilà donc
et alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant on
pourrait se dire qu'évidemment c'est bon
ça aurait pu tomber là comme ça aurait
pu tomber n'importe où à part je veux
dire ça n'est que du que des séquences
de collagène et bien figurez vous qu'il
n'ya pas longtemps on a réussi à sortir
l'adn mitochondrial de ces bêtes là donc
on a aussi des séquences d'adé n est que
on a retrouvé le même arbre enfin les
gens qui ont fait les analyses ont
retrouvé exactement le même arbre donc
le même clad qu'ils appellent les paons
périseaux dactyle avec macro kenya et
oxo dont qui forment un groupe frère et
groupe frère défunt qui sont aux groupes
qui sont groupe frère et qui sont
eux-mêmes groupe frère des périseaux
dactyle donc maintenant eh ben on aurait
peut-être les amis on aurait peut-être
les méridiens ongulés qui serait en fait
le groupe frère dépérissent au dactyle
et ça je trouve quand même que c'est de
la bombe de balle ça envoie du boudin
créole comme dirait l'autre et non c'est
plutôt cool c'est plutôt cool parce que
c'était vraiment un mystère de longue
date d'où sortait ccc meridian gueulé et
maintenant d'avoir une bonne piste
à la fois fossiles mais aussi génétique
pour ces animaux c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment cool
alors voilà oui le voilà ce fameux ce
fameux arbre qui a été fait à partir de
l'adn mitochondrial donc vous voyez
c'est exactement le même arbre un
maquereau kenya toxo dont et l'épée
risso dactyle de ce côté là et puis
évidemment et bien il y aller xena retr
les xena retr qui sont le groupe sud
américain qui a réussi à survivre
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui parmi
lesquels donc je vous le disais dans la
première leçon dans le premier cours on
retrouve donc les omnivores que sont
l'état tous les singles ata les
herbivores que sont les folies vorace et
à dire les paresseux et les insectivores
que sont les vermines un goy c'est à
dire les fourmiliers
et alors comme je voulais dit le
registre fossile il aurait tendance à
remonter jusqu à l'eocène donc on
retrouve on retrouve des fossiles très
abondant jusqu'à l'éocène et notamment
le premier crâne de xena retr qu'on
retrouve dans le registre fossile il
date de l'oligocène mais avant ça on a
quand même ici et là quelques fragments
osseux notamment des restes de de
carapace des restes de carapace de tapir
des ostéo derme et c'est ostéo dernier
on arrive à en retrouver jusque dans le
palais aux scènes donc donc ça c'est
quand même super intéressant parce que
bas parce que ça veut dire que déjà les
déjà les singularités et le clad que
forment les folies vohra et les les
vermines un goy et est différenciée au
paléo scène donc encore une fois ça
colle bien avec une origine profondément
dans le crétacé
alors les xena retrait je vous le disais
lors de la première leçon ils ont
plusieurs caractères en commun plusieurs
caractères morphologiques en commun qui
font que ça faisait partie de ces
groupes dont on connaît dont on avait
déjà reconnu l'existence formelle avant
même d'avoir les phylogénie moléculaire
donc déjà le moc reinhardt rend lui-même
signifie articulations étrange pourquoi
parce que au lieu d'avoir une seule
facette d'articulation sur les vertèbres
pour que les allées vertes elles
s'articulent les unes avec les autres
eh bien ils en ont deux voyez une deux
convois ici s'articuler les unes avec
les autres
une deux donc sur la colonne vertébrale
et ils ont aussi d un sacre sommes donc
c'est à dire une
une grande quantité de vertèbre qui sont
complètement fusionner entre elles et
avec le bassin comme un oiseau en fait
donc ce sacre hommes c'est vraiment un
caractère typique de xena retr et enfin
les griffes qui sont gigantesques chez
absolument tous les groupes de xena retr
on a aussi la particularité d'avoir
cette espèce de cette espèce de deux
processus
jules galles en fait le processus je
gagne qui est une surface d'insertion
pour les muscles massé terre qu'on
retrouve chez beaucoup d'espèces
éteintes de xena retrouve donc les clips
taux dont tu les
les paresseux les paresseux géant mais
aussi les paresseux terrestre les
paresseux moderne et enfin on a un
caractère qui est très intéressant qui
est la présence de cette gouttière ici
que vous voyez donc il ya pas d'assise
yves chez les paresseux ou chez les ja
pas décisif chez les xen artres mais par
contre il y à cette espèce de gouttière
ici qu'on retrouve chez les xhosas
retraités comme le clip taux dont tu es
le paresseux géant et qu'on retrouve
évidemment chez le fourmilier est en
fait chez le fourmilier cette gouttière
elle sert à faire passer la longue
langue vermiforme et ça du coup ça et ça
ça va de pair du coup avec la perte
totale de l'émail et la simplification
de la morphologie des dents qui est si
typique d'exane artres au quinquennat
retrait n'a d'émail et tous ont une
morphologie dentaire extrêmement simple
et ça du coup ça rappelle hélas ça
rappelle les autres fourmilier donc les
les oryctérope que vous voyez à droite
ont aussi des saints des incisives
absence une espèce de gouttière au bout
de la mâchoire et pour faire passer la
longue langue et une morphologie
dentaire extrêmement simple sans émail
les pangolins ils ont carrément tout
perdu au niveau des dents ils ont aussi
une langue vermiforme et on avait vu
aussi les parmi les hyènes donc les pros
tels qu'ils sont en voie de perdre leurs
dents aussi et qu'ils ont une très très
large palais qui leur permet de faire
passer une très une langue très grosse
et ça du coup ça ça en plus des grosses
griffes qu'on retrouve chez tous les
xena retr ça semble indiquer un mode de
vie qui devait ancestralement enfin un
ancêtre commun d'aidé xena retr qui
devait d'ores et déjà être un
un fourmilier en fait donc le fourmilier
en fait ce serait l'espèce bien que ça
ait l'air de l'espèce la plus dérivé du
groupe où l'une des espèces les plus
dérivé du groupe va en réalité ça se
trouve c'est peut-être là la forme
ancestrale finalement des dizaines
artres et les autres xena retrouverait
ensuite ré évolué de grosses dents et
notamment les grands herbivores que sont
l'église taux dont télé les paresseux
terrestre lors leurs dents en fête
aurait évolué mais à partir de gênes qui
avait déjà fortement dégénéré et qui
essaient était déjà fortement muté du
cous ils n'ont pas pure forme et de
l'émail et ils n'ont pas pu
ils n'ont pas pu reformer une
morphologie dentaire complexe à partir
de ces gènes détériorer on va dire de
ces gènes dentaire est détériorée donc
voilà ça c'est une des hypothèses comme
quoi comme quoi les xen art relance est
déguisé nar traitait déjà fourmilier il
avait déjà des grosses griffes pour
défoncer les termitières il avait déjà
une langue vermiforme et il avait déjà
perdu une bonne partie de ses dents ou
du moins de sa complexité dentaire et
son émail et il y a une chose aussi que
tout que les xena retr semble partagée
c'est la présence d'ostéo derme donc je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure on retrouve
on retrouve des os théo derme
apparemment jusqu'au paléocène
et ça c'est peut-être pas anodin c'est
peut-être parce que les osthéos derme
ils ne sont pas que typique des d'état
tout peut-être qu'en fait ils se
trouvent tous les xena à la base avait
des ostéo derme et là ce que vous voyez
en fait c'est un fragment de peau d'un
paresseux terrestre fragments de peau
momifié de paresseux terrestre où vous
voyez très clairement les osthéos derme
à l'intérieur de la peau de paresseux
donc les paresseux aussi avait des ostéo
dern et par optimisation phylogénétique
il n'est pas complètement impossible
d'envisager qu'en fait tout les xena
retravailler des ostéo d'air mais que
tous et ostéo derme qu'on voudrait
attribuées finalement à la famille des
tatous donc les cinq du latin tous et
ostéo d'armes qu'on voudrait a attribué
à la famille du tattoo jusqu'au
paléocène serait en fait distribuer plus
équitablement entre la branche des piles
osa et la branche des cinq du latin
alors évidemment les le groupe d'exane
artres ne manque pas d espèces d'espèces
emblématiques je vous parle évidemment
du méga terium qui avait décrit enfin
week avait décrit cuvier à l'époque où
il invente et encore il était encore en
train d'inventer la paléontologie des
vertébrés
donc voici mes gars terium tel que
reconstitué au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris
et il ya évidemment les clips taux dont
tu donc les tatous géant dont on
retrouve donc ça c'est le squelette avec
l'armure ça c'est le squelette sans
l'armée parce qu'il faut savoir que
contrairement aux tortues l'armure n'est
faite que de peau aussi fier comme chez
les tatous moderne
le squelette en dessous c'est un
squelette de mammifères extrêmement
modifier mes classiques et vous voyez
d'ailleurs très bien le sacrum ici
toutes les vertèbres fusionner et
fusionner avec le bassin sur ce sur ce
clip tente alors c'est vous voyez la
morphologie est superbe arrêt 1
là je veux dire on ne peut pas faire la
liste de toutes les six napo morphy d'un
squelette pareil quoi ça prendrait
vraiment trop longtemps
alors là on va regarder plus précisément
justement du côté des départs est ce
parce que chez les paresseux on a eu une
énorme diversité une énorme diversité
qui a été très très bien étudié durant
une diversité qui a date de l'oligocène
du miocène et du pliocène diversité qui
a chuté aujourd'hui donc diversité qui
était essentiellement d'ailleurs dominé
par des espèces terrestres
donc ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on
appellerait nous des paresseux géant bon
ils n'étaient pas tous géant il y en a
qui était de taille normale mais
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient géant parmi
les notes aux terres idées les méga
terre idée donc noto terium il était
notre eau terium été gigantesque méga
terium était gigantesque
mégalo knicks étaient gigantesques
mégalo knicks d'ailleurs qui a été le
premier paresseux géant décrit est
décrit par ni plus ni moins que le
quatrième président des états unis
thomas jefferson qui était président des
états unis oui mais paléontologues aussi
voilà donc donc c'est quand même une
histoire assez intéressante
l'histoire des paresseux géant et comme
je vous le disais du coup c'est une
histoire qui est connu depuis très
longtemps à le quatrième président des
états unis c'était dans les années 1800
au début du 19e siècle donc alors j'ai
déjà les paresseux géant ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant à noter c'est que ils
marchent en fait sur sur le une marche
au niveau de leurs pieds ils marchent en
fait sur le côté des pieds et non pas
sur la plante des pieds donc ils ne sont
ni digi tigran ni plantigrade ni quoi
que ce soit ils sont je sais pas quoi
grade mais en tout cas ils marchent sur
le cinquième métatarse et vous pouvez
voir que le cinquième métatarse est
extrêmement modifié chez les paresseux
et vous pouvez voir aussi que du coup il
y à une réduction ça va de pair avec une
réduction du nombre de doigts donc chez
les 1000 aux dons innés qui sont plus
basses eaux dans la phylogénie vous avez
à deux trois quatre doigts alors que
chez les médiaterre idée vous n'avez
plus que 1 2 3 doigts et entre 2 vous
avez encore des paresseux comme les
troupes notre terre idées qui ont quatre
doigts mais dont l'un des voilà le la
des doigts commencent à perdre ses
phalanges donc voilà il ya une tendance
du coup à la réduction du nombre de
doigts qui va de pair avec cette marche
sur les côtés du pied chez les paresseux
géant
vous avez aussi alors fait notable chez
les paresseux géant
certaines espèces étaient frileuses
alors maintenant je vous ai je vous
donne à vous imaginez ce que ça donne
une espèce de paresseux géant
fouisseuses et là bas vous n'avez pas
beaucoup à imaginer parce que là vous
avez une caverne qui a été entièrement
creusée par des paresseux géant en
témoignent les traces de griffes contre
les parois
vous voyez les traces de griffes qui ont
été faites par les glyphes énorme des
paresseux géant je peux vous montrer la
voie la méga terium voyez c'est énorme
griffe la balle et vala les paresseux
géant il était du genre à balancer leurs
griffes contre les murs pour creuser et
en fait c'est pas tant un terrier qui a
été construit ce tout en une fois en
fait que le départ et ce géant qui
revenait au même endroit voyez pour soi
pour hiberner soit pour pour estives et
on sait pas exactement puisque les
paresseux modernes n'ont pas du tout ce
comportement là mais en tout cas ils
devaient revenir de façon régulière
probablement annuel pour creuser en fait
pour creuser une nouvelle cavités qui
venait élargir en fait la précédente
jusqu'à creuser comme je vous le voyez
ici des tunnels littéralement des
tunnels mais toute cette diversité est
bien là chuté à deux espèces aujourd'hui
et deux espèces qui ont la particularité
d'être arboricole en plus enfin pas deux
espèces de genre de genre mais il ya
quand même plus que deux espèces g chez
les paresseux moderne mais voilà il
reste plus que 2 jean deux genres qui ne
sont ni géant ni terrestre en fait et et
ça devient intéressant là où l'on
constate qu'en fait ces deux genres qui
sont ni terrestre enfin qu'ils sont tous
les deux arboricole et de petite taille
en fait ils ont tous les deux évolué de
façon totalement indépendante
c'est à dire que vous avez le les vous
avez les bras d'ipo d'idées donc que
voici que voilà vous avez les bras d'ipo
d'idées qui ont trois griffes donc les
ce sont les fameux paresseux à trois
griffes qui sont les plus basses eaux de
tous les paresseux et vous avez
de l'autre côté les co et l'opus qui
font partie de la famille des mégalos
nick idée de la même famille que mega
l'onyx donc écho et l'opus qui est le
paresseux à deux doigts et qu'on
distingue aussi par la morphologie
crânienne puisque les bras d'ipo d'idées
brady puces se distingue le crâne de
brady puces se distingue de celui de
cauet l'opus parce qu'il n'a pas de
canini forme alors on peut pas parler
vraiment de canines évidemment chez les
paresseux puisque les dents sont
complètement simplifiée et non ont perdu
les mailles
mais chez les méga le ch est le co est
l'opus en fait on a des grosses canini
forme qui n'existe pas chez brady puce
en fait donc voilà le paresseux à trois
doigts et le paresseux à deux doigts ne
sont pas du tout proche parent en
réalité ils sont très éloignés ils ont
un ancêtre en commun qui vivait à le
ligue au sen le dernier ancêtre commun
qui l'on vivait à l'oligocène et c'est
l'ancêtre commun de tous les paresseux
paresseux terrestre inclus donc voilà
l'histoire en fait des paresseux elle
est formidable parce que c'est
essentiellement une histoire terrestre
dont il ne reste aujourd'hui que des
espèces arboricoles petit ajout en cours
de montage puisque entre le moment où
j'ai fini d'enregistrer cette vidéo est
le moment où je la publie sur internet
eh bien il ya deux études qui sont
sortis simultanément et qui ont
complètement chamboulé l'arbre évolutif
des paresseux donc c'est des études qui
sont basés sur le lait les protéines des
paresseux géant ainsi que sur donc la
première était basé sur les protéines
des paresseux géant et l'autre est basé
sur le génome mitochondrial est donc ces
deux études ont de façon complètement
indépendante et bien retrouvé le même
arbre évolutif le même arbre
phylogénétique pour les paresseux et il
se trouve qu'il est totalement à
l'opposé de ce que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure voilà il est totalement à
l'opposé pourquoi et bien parce que en
fait le paresseux à deux doigts donc qu
est l'opus se trouve à la base de
l'arbre
alors que le paresseux à trois doigts
sauce où se trouve tout en haut de
l'arbre aux côtés
des mégalos liquider ce qui était
totalement l'opposé le regarder cet
arbre là c'était brady puces à la base
le paresseux à trois doigts qui était à
la base et c'est cauet l'opus le
paresseux à deux doigts qui se trouvait
tout en haut de l'arbre au sein des
mégalos nikki des bombes à là c'est
totalement le contraire c'est n'importe
quoi
voilà la génétique et enfin les
caractères moléculaire continue de
mettre en pls les caractères
morphologiques c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant en fait que les
deux analyses soient sortis en même
temps je sais pas s'ils se sont
concertés ou quoi mais c'est
impressionnant que les deux analyses
soient sortis en même temps et c'est
surtout magnifique qu'elle retrouve
exactement le même résultat
donc c'est un petit peu comme justement
les l'arbre que je vous ai montré du
coup tout à l'heure avec les
l'hélicoptère n'est les notes ont gueulé
les deux analyses c'était pareil c'était
les protéines et les
les l'adn mitochondrial qui ont retrouvé
le même arbre indépendamment donc la paf
quoi voilà donc comme je le disais la le
paresseux à 3 doit donc se retrouve aux
côtés de milo dont donc au sein au sein
des minots d'auto idea
et puis ici vous avez méga therion le
fameux méga terium aux côtés de mégalo
knicks donc celui découvert par thomas
jefferson et vous avez brady puces qui
se trouve au sein de cela et du coup ça
veut dire que cauet l'opus je vous ai
parlé de sa canine tout à l'heure la
canine de cauet l'opus c'était un des
caractères forts qu'il honnit qui le lié
justement oméga l'oni qui dès la
présence d'une canine était partagé avec
les mains mégalo nikki débat du coup
avec cauet l'opus qui se retrouve à la
base ça veut dire que la présence d'une
canine
soit elle est complètement convergentes
soit aller complètement ancestrales et
puis à côté de ça vous avez les donc
encore une fois vous avez et fait de la
géographie extrêmement puissant sur la
phylogénie des mammifères balle à vous
retrouver encore cet effet de la
géographie puisque à la base de l'arbre
on retrouve un club qui est uniquement
qui est très localisée sur les caraïbes
donc vous voyez ces deux c2 paresseux et
1c de ces deux genres de paresseux et à
qui appartiennent aux mêmes clad des
mégalos kinoïde et bien ils se
retrouvent ensemble donc voilà les
paresseux des caraïbes et les paresseux
du continent donc de nouveau une
séparation qui tient de
de la géographie donc la géographie
puissant facteur conducteur de la
phylogénie des mammifères une fois de
plus mais évidemment comme vous pouvez
le voir ça ne change rien au fait que
l'arboriculture soit convergentes chez
le paresseux à deux doigts et chez le
paresseux à trois doigts qui reste
définitivement séparés par un très grand
nombre de paresseux terrestre et
d'ailleurs c'est pas que une histoire
terrestre
je fais un raccourci là puisqu'en
réalité il y avait aussi des espèces
aquatiques et notamment les espèces du
genre thalasso cnu ce qu'ils ont été
découverts par des parlers paléontologue
du muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
notamment christian de musan en amérique
du sud dans la formation de pisco et
donc vous pouvez voir c'est c'est
paresseux aquatique avec une densité
osseuse extrêmement élevé et on peut
suivre l'évolution de cette densité
osseuse dans le genre thalasso cnu ce
donc depuis l'état l'a soutenu ce les
plus basses eaux jusqu'au talent a
soutenu ce n'est plus des rives et la
densité osseuse devient de plus en plus
élevés et là en fait les membres
agissent de plus en plus comme des
ballasts comme c'était le cas d'ailleurs
chez les cétacés bazzo comme un do is us
et on a aussi évidemment une rétraction
des narines qui va de pair avec
l'adaptation à la nage et cette petite
image qui vous montrent qu'en fait les
paresseux modernes ne sont pas si mal à
l'aise que ça quand il s'agit de nage et
voilà mais voilà toutes les bonnes
choses ont une fin et la fin de cette
histoire approche à grands pas puisque à
la limite entre le pliocène et le
pléistocène c'est-à-dire il ya deux
millions d'années
eh bien les mouvements tectoniques qui
font naître la chaîne des andes et le
bassin de l'amazone y vont déjà
bouleversé le climat de l'amérique du
sud parce que quand vous créez quand
vous voyez apparaître une chaîne de
montagnes un nouveau bassin sédimentaire
et un bassin aussi forestiers tels que
l'amazonie la chaîne de montagnes des
andes déjà au niveau climatique ça
n'augure rien de bon
1 que les choses soient claires mais
surtout les mêmes mouvements tectoniques
font naître de l'autre côté de
l'amérique les montagnes rocheuses et
font émerger entre les andes et les
montagnes rocheuses le fameux isme de
panama qui crée pour la première fois
depuis soit depuis plus de 60 millions
d'années va créer une connexion entre
l'amérique du nord et l'amérique du sud
et là il va y avoir des échanges
phonique entre les deux continents
échanges phonique qui vont être
majoritairement à la défaveur des
espèces sud américaine
ou qui au final ou et non le bilan final
ça va quand même être la défaveur des
espèces américaine est donc cet
événement ça s'appelle le gaby pour
great american gothic interchange donc
le grand inter change biologique ou
biotique américain donc le grand inter
change qu'on l'appelle généralement le
grand interchangeant parce qu'il n'ya
pas vraiment il n'ya pas vraiment
d'autres événements qu'on appelle des
grands intérêts changent
on pourrait parler de grand intérêt
change pour l'arrivée des arceaux
dactyle et dépérissent au dactyle en
afrique et la sortie des pelles on les
paie non du lait d'africains 21 millions
d'années mais ça s'appelle déjà le gong
fu therion datum event où le
proboscidiens d'atouts et datum event
donc ce sera déjà un nom et ça s'appelle
pas un intérêt change et le l'événement
d'interchange qu'il y a eu à l'arrivée
des arceaux d'actifs et des périseaux
d'acted d'asie dans l'europe qui était
autrefois insulaires ne s'appelle pas
une interchanger il s'appelle la grande
coupure donc voilà il n'ya pas donc
jusqu'à présent et après entre l'asie et
entre l'asie et l'amérique du nord les
connexions ont été tellement tellement
régulière qu'il y en a aucune qu'on
appelle the interchanger quoi donc voilà
si vous parlez du grand inter change
généralement c'est que vous faites
référence aux grands interchangeant
biotique américains ou biologiques
américain alors qui sont les nouveaux
arrivants et bien ce sont les espèces
déjà on va pas on va parler des nouveaux
arrivants qui viennent d'amérique du
nord et ses nouveaux arrivants ce sont
les espèces qu'on associe volontiers à
l'âge de glace
c'est pour ça que je vous ai mis plein
de petites références à l'âge de glace
alors on a
on a les canidés déjà qu'ils arrivent
d'amérique du nord donc les loups
typiquement qui arrivent d'amérique du
nord mais qui vont qui comme vous le
savez aujourd'hui vont pas tenir
longtemps en amérique du sud puisque on
ne trouve plus de 2 d'espèces de loups
sauvages en amérique du sud
on a des proboscidiens et notamment qu
viejo news donc là je vous ai mis un
mammouth c'est un peu trompeur mais bon
les mammouths sur plus connus mais qu
viejo news c'est un mastodonte et donc
vous avez qu viraux news qui arrive en
amérique du sud qui est un descendant
des mammouths d'amérique des des
mammouths des à des mastodontes
américains d'amérique du nord donc
donc imaginer qu'il ya eu des
proboscidiens en amérique du sud vous
imaginez un éléphant en amazonie quoi ce
serait de la balle on a eu évidemment
les tigres à dents de sabre les smilodon
idées qui sont arrivés en amérique du
sud et qui sont venus concurrencer les
ti la qos milus donc les bords y ait une
idée sur leur propre territoire et qu'il
est qui les ont tous trait d'ailleurs
les périodes acte ils arrivent en
amérique du sud donc on a eu des chevaux
sud-américains notamment un qui
s'appelle lippi dion a chipé pé i do you
and i pillion donc qui a vécu une bonne
partie du pliocène et du pléistocène en
amérique du sud mais qui a fini par
disparaître
vous avez les tapirs les ancêtres des
tapirs l'état les tapirs qui vivent
toujours en amérique du sud
vous avez les les ancêtres des
jaguar donc jaguar qui vivent toujours
en afrique du sud en amérique du sud et
donc là où c'est intéressant c'est qu'il
ya vous vous imaginez n'y avait pas de
jaguar en amérique du sud avant et
évidemment les camélidés donc les
ancêtres des lamas et des guanacos qui
arrive aussi à cette même époque en
amérique du sud
donc tout ça va rentrer en compétition
avec les espèces sud américaine est là
et le l'issue va être funeste pour la
plupart des représentants de la faune
sud-américaine donc il ya guère que
quelques veinards qui vont tirer leur
épingle du jeu
les xena retr qu'on voit toujours
aujourd'hui mais la plupart des la
plupart des grands xena retour notamment
les grands herbivores comme les clips
thonon télé paresseux géant vont
reconnaître vont finir par s'éteindre et
donc il ya que les xena retrait les
opossums qui vont finir qui vont finir
par suivre au niveau des marsupiaux way
à part les opossums n'y a pas grand
chose qui va survivre donc label
diversité de ce parasol honte là bas ça
va ça va être rapidement poutrer et
alors on a pas des masses d'explication
on a pas des masses d'explication pour
pour expliquer pourquoi certains groupes
vont survivre et pas d'autres donc voilà
une façon plus graphique de représenter
la même chose donc vous avez ici l'état
tous les paresseux géant les frustre
acide et l'église taux dont tu les
opossums du coup les toxo dont tu es
l'hélicoptère vous voyez que à part les
tox aux autres
tout a été représenté dans l'âge de
glace d'ailleurs donc quand je vous
disais que ça faisait très référence à
l'âge de glace donc tous ces attaques
sont au début du pléistocène vont se
disperser en amérique du nord depuis
l'amérique du sud donc ils vont
participer à l'intervention partir
d'amérique du sud et conquérir une bonne
partie de l'amérique du nord bon il faut
pas aller plus loin que l'amérique du
nord mais ils vont quand même y avoir un
petit succès évolutif
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
tous représentés dans l'âge de glace et
c'est parce que les tox aux dons et
l'hélicoptère ne sont plus survivre
jusqu'à il y à quelques quelques juste
une dizaine de milliers d'années même
même un peu moins que ça et bien qu'on a
réussi à retrouver leurs gènes et qu'on
a pu faire des phylogénie on a aussi
retrouvé des des tissus momifié comme je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure de
paresseux géant et on a pu faire des
analyses génétiques de paresseux géant
et aussi 2 de glee pto dont tu donc
cessé d espèces qui ont qui sont qui se
sont éteintes beaucoup plus récemment
que le grand inter change américains
pourquoi parce qu'elles ont traversé le
détroit
enfin à l'isthme de panama et ont réussi
à pendant une période d'au moins à
s'installer en amérique du nord
en plus de leur présence en amérique du
sud et en plus de leur survie en
amérique du sud
mais puisque aujourd'hui eh bien vous ne
pouvez plus voir ni de faugeras idées ni
de griptonite ni de paresseux géant ni
même de ses clips taux de ces toxo dont
tu es de ces dites optèrent et bien
c'est qu'ils ont fini par s'éteindre et
ils ont fini par s'éteindre quant à la
fin du dernier âge glaciaire donc il ya
dix mille ans tout ce beau monde finit
par disparaître soit à cause de
l'arrivée de l'homme soit suite aux
changements climatiques
voilà graphiquement parlant et bien les
forêts sera si des ailés les forces
tracy des mais aussi les autres les
marsupiaux carnivores vont complètement
être concurrencé par les chiens et les
gros chat et vont se faire [ __ ] et sur
leur propre terrain les paresseux géant
vont aussi finir par s'éteindre après
avoir quand même pendant une période et
migrer vers l'amérique du nord
les clips taux dont tu c'est pareil ils
vont finir par s'éteindre mais après
avoir pendant un petit moment et migrer
vers l'amérique du nord donc ils ont eu
un dernier rebond
évolutif avant de mourir les tox aux
dons qui eux aussi vont se retrouver en
amérique du nord et l'hélicoptère mais
qui vont finir par s'éteindre et
l'hélicoptère eux aussi amérique du nord
et aussi vont finir par s'éteindre
donc les seuls survivants aujourd'hui ce
sont les opossums et les tatous qui sont
d'ailleurs eux aussi en train d'envahir
l'amérique du nord
j'espère que ce n'est pas le prémice
d'une extinction futur parce que jusqu'à
présent ça leur a pas trop réussi aux
autres ça n'aura pas réussi du tout donc
là vous pouvez voir donc la liste d'un
d'envahisseurs venus d'amérique du nord
vous voyez qu'elle est vous voyez
qu'elle est longue mais qui à certaines
espèces qui vivent encore aujourd'hui
notamment les pécaris voilà les tapirs
donc il vous imaginez n'y avait pas de
paix car ils n'ont plus les ours donc
les ancêtres des ours à lunettes qui
arrive
vous avez des lapins il n'y avait pas de
lapin n'avait pas de lapin il y avait
des rongeurs y avait des rongeurs mais
y'avait pas de lapin vous imaginez
évidemment les mastodontes qui ont fini
par s'éteindre
mais il ya quand même donc je disais des
espèces qu'ils vont traverser de l'autre
côté et finir par atteindre l'amérique
du nord
donc ces espèces donc c'est celle que
dont je parlais tout à l'heure il ya les
opossums qui vivent encore les
porcs-épics donc les porcs-épics qui
sont qui sont considérés on peut les
considérer comme assimilés sud
américains ils viennent d'afrique à la
base mais ils ont ce sont des districts
au goliath qui ont évolué pendant 40
millions d'années en amérique du sud les
tatous les tatous géant donc les tatous
géant je vous disais l'église thonon
devons passer en amérique du nord
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont si populaires
pour chez les américains avant de finir
par disparaître il ya entre
entre 20000 même pas entre 30000 et dix
mille ans tous vont finir par toutes ces
espèces la dont je vous ai montré ce
body count cela disparaît entre 30000 et
dix mille ans et une bonne partie fait
partie justement du body quand des êtres
humains
et puis évidemment les paresseux géant
les capybara ou aussi remonté visibles
d'après 7,7
d'après cette image et les toques ce don
donc les toc ce donc que je vous ai
montré là et alors l'élément quand
justement là cela parce que ça vous
montre les mammifères mais les manquants
ce sont les faux rustre acide et vous
avez notamment tita nice est un faux
russe race idée qui va on va qui va
passer en amérique du nord mais pendant
l'ère glaciaire justement pendant la
dette pendant l'âge de glace
il va il va chasser les chevaux locaux
donc c'est une image très connu à le
titanic qui chasse le cheval dans les
grandes plaines d'amérique du nord
et bien ça c'est c'est aussi un migrant
donc c'est effectivement un interchanger
7 interchangeant méricain ça marche dans
les deux sens mais il ya quand même
beaucoup plus d'espèces qui vont venir
d'amérique du nord pour envahir
l'amérique du sud est il ya il ya
beaucoup moins d'espèces qui vont partir
d'amérique du sud pour arriver en
amérique du nord
la plupart d'entre elles vont pas
connaître un gros succès évolutif en
tout cas pas très longtemps juste
pendant le pléistocène et puis elles
vont s'éteindre avec l'arrivée de
l'holocène donc l'être humain et la fin
de la glaciation et surtout le body
count le nombre d'espèces qui finit par
s'éteindre par concurrence à cause des
des arrivants sud américain en amérique
du nord
il n'est pas si élevé que ça alors que
le nombre de taxons qui vont s'éteindre
en amérique du sud
suite à l'arrivée des espèces d'amérique
du nord là par contre je vous en ai site
est plein il ya laisse par aso dont il
est il y aller la quasi totalité la
quasi totalité de tous ces groupes
d'ailleurs qui va s'éteindre à part ceux
qui auront réussi à migrer en amérique
du nord donc donc le maquereau kenya
c'est le dernier d'hélicoptères ne les
clips taux dont tu sais les derniers des
tatous des tatous géant
les paresseux
donc les paresseux géant bon là il va y
avoir quand même pas mal de paris se
gère en amérique du nord il ya du mégalo
knicks il ya du d'une autre terium donc
ça va aller mais c'est surtout mégalo
knicks des mégalos nick idée qui m'ont
passé en amérique du nord
bon évidemment il j'exclus l'état tous
et à tous normaux on va dire du compte
mais voilà donc donc c'est un à terre
change certes mais qui est fortement
inégal qui est fortement inégale et ça
ça on sait pas trop pourquoi en fait on
aujourd'hui on n'a pas trop idée de
pourquoi en fait c'est un terreau change
a été si inégale et a été tellement la
défaveur des espèces sud américaine
alors que pourtant elle était sur leur
terrain donc c'est ça qui est bizarre
est bon alors l'un des trucs plus il ya
des hypothèses qui ont été avancées
évidemment pour dire que les places
inter qui vivaient en amérique du nord
et est supérieur aux places inter et aux
marsupiaux qui vivaient en amérique du
sud
parce que l'amérique du nord a eu un
climat plus perturbé donc il était mieux
adapter aux changements climatiques et
rallie tralala la vérité c'est qu'on
raisonne à posteriori et et comme l'a
dit stephen jay gould il est fort
probable que si on a si on étaient
parachutés il y à 2,1 millions d'années
avec aucune connaissance de ce qui
allait se produire au moment de la
formation de l'isthme de panama
on aurait probablement donné les sud
américains gagnant quoi où on parce
qu'ils sont chez eux quoi je veux dire
on aurait probablement fait l'hypothèse
que l'isthme de panama allait être un
détail mineur de l'évolution de ces
groupes qu'ils allaient se rencontrer au
milieu se faire concurrence mais que
jamais il y aurait eu d'interchange en
fait parce qu'ils se seront tellement
fait concurrence au milieu que rien ne
se serait produit donc comme le dit
gould si on devait rembobinez l'histoire
évolutive
ce serait impossible de deviner dans
quel sens que dans quelle direction
aller
elle irait et se serait il serait très
improbable d'ailleurs qu'elle irait dans
la même direction que celle qu'elle
avait pris qu'elle avait pris dans un
premier temps c'est à dire que si on
devait rejouer l'interchange legrand
interchanger nord américain il est fort
probable que le résultat soit
complètement différent qui avait pas de
prédispositions pour cette faune nord
américaine à prendre le dessus sur la
faune sud américaine voilà donc en
conclusion et bien cette cette histoire
de 62,2 de plus de 60 millions d'années
d'isolement de l'amérique du sud et bien
c'est sait rien d'eux c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'un énorme laboratoire delà de
l'évolution en milieu en milieu
c'est comme c'est comme si l'évolution
des mammifères en fait avait avait eu
une condition contrôle
si vous préférez donc vous avez
l'évolution des mammifères sur les
autres continents où il ya eu des
intérêts changent mais quasiment tout le
temps voilà bon là à part à part en
australie évidemment mais l'afrique elle
a fini par être connecté avec le reste
du continent l'europe a fini par être
connecté le japon a fini par être
connecté
l'amérique du sud allait rester
quasiment un touché à part par les
rongeurs et les primates mais elle est
restée quasiment un touché pendant 60
millions d'années et du coup et bien on
a eu on a eu des exemples de magnifiques
exemples de donc d'un isolement qui a
conduit à une vie car y ans de certaines
lignes et donc une évolution
complètement séparée des autres
on a eu l'effet des convergences
évolutif donc on a vu des convergence
évolutive étonnante entre les espèces
qui vivaient en amérique du sud et les
autres celles qui vivaient en dehors
d'amérique du sud
on a eu l'enregistrement de d'arrivée de
d'espèces invasives donc les rongeurs et
les primates qui sont arrivés malgré la
séparation est tous assez enregistré
avec un détail assez ahurissant dans le
registre fossile d'amérique du sud qui
est très très riches et c'est ça qui est
beau c'est ça qui est beau c'est que le
registre fossile d'amérique du sud une
des très très riches et qu'ils donnent
beaucoup de détails sur la façon dont
tous ces phénomènes ont eu lieu se sont
déroulés comment la diversité s'est
construite à partir de souches de
mammifères totalement différente du
reste du monde dont c'est un formidable
laboratoire de l'évolution c'est ce que
j'ai écrit là c'est une aire cénozoïque
alternative qui a eu lieu en amérique du
sud avec des dinosaures carnivores donc
défaut rustre acide et avec voilà des
des choses assez formidables
donc voilà mais tout ça évidemment comme
je disais a fini par prendre fin gaby
est passée par là et gaby a tout tué
donc
mais j'ai presque envie de dire ça a
tout tué pour notre plus grand bonheur
parce que ça rend justement le registre
fossile d'amérique du sud d'autant plus
important que ça permet de comprendre
s'il n'y a que par le registre fossile
finalement qu'on peut arriver à
comprendre ce qui s'est passé en
amérique du sud et on peut joindre les
paléontologues joignent leurs forces
avec les avec les généticiens pour pour
arriver à obtenir l'image la plus
complète de l'évolution de ces
mammifères cette évolution unique qui a
fini par complètement s'effondrer il ya
deux millions d'années
donc voila c'était l'amérique du sud
ça a été plus court que d'habitude il
fallait bien se reposer après avoir
enchaîné les primates et les hominidés
c'était des gros morceaux
voilà donc je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine où on va avoir notre dernière
notre dernier cours qui sera sur
l'origine des mammifères et l'évolution
des synapses id voilà à la semaine
prochaine ciao